okay there there are a couple things
we're working on here uh one he go he's
going okay it's just he he's just
representing linear assault okay the the
first one is that I have to create get
out of weapon retention issue range okay
so I'm going to move away from him so my
angle of deviation goes opposite my
angle deflection so that I can start to
generate room to draw the
weapon
secondarily I am going to start spinning
this fight around so you have your iido
spiraling uh footwork so I'm going to
spiral this fight around okay so I'm
turning now he has to turn to get me
okay that's what you
want and then thirdly I'm I'm going to
connect to his Center so that I get that
little
micro uh projection as we're going so
here as we go slow boom I have I'm going
to project into his body because of this
joint so just like if I was below his
Ahad stick your arms just like I was
below you can put that one just as I was
below the elbow That Elbow will hinge so
you smack that hard you might not get
the angle deviation in here that you
want and same thing here the the
shoulder can hinge and you'll lose some
of that so when you come above the elbow
boom it's got to be in his Center
because of the inertia he's not going to
go that way he's still probably going to
go somewhere south of the 180 here but
he's definitely going to go that way and
that helps accomplish what I'm trying to
do in the other two things all right and
then the fourth thing is you can't be
already in that mindset that of like a
okay because you're going to run away
you're going to run away or you're going
to stti stick to him and now you're in
that other range
okay I'm I'm Ting him as he goes I
already know he's going I already know
he he's going and I want him deeper into
the salt that will help everything that
you're trying to do just like sword
workor if I start defending myself early
you're going to start adjusting into
what I'm doing okay so I kind of I got
to wait Bo boom to come
around be calm here and there's a little
bit of English as I'm doing this I
haven't moved yet do you see let him
in boom
boom you go a little
faster if you pay attention on that that
second aspect the projection I don't
extend my
elbow he hits he hits the hard point
Boom the faster he goes the smaller it
can be
to okay let's bring those things in
Don't Run Away From The Assault you want
them deeper into it okay here we go so
on this one we'll move away from the
abstraction and someone's trying to get
the bicep tie and and the and the uh
clinch okay as they're trying to do so
boom you have a lot of stuff that you
can do with that from that bicep TI and
the clinch okay so he's trying to do the
bicep tie and the clinch okay that's
what he's doing well this is like a kind
of left h a left hook do you see yes sir
so I'm going to go inside of
it
it's inside of it again egg him on boom
and now you'll have the shoulder for the
projection Point
okay if you need to you can deflex you
see yes sir boom
boom again don't run away from him you
want to bit him into that you bit him
into
it and then you have your distance and
your
draw
watch my grounding
foot this has to be grounded it can't be
up it grounds his weight comes into me
that's what it grounds and there's this
foot
okay keep that other foot outside foot
on the ground Here We Go sir